we've just finished the pasado on
saturday night live on on television
and you know to millions of people and
we've i've got through i'm so happy
and uh and he says can i have a word of
you outside
and i think he's going to tell me that
i've been booked for michael mcintyre's
big show of bbc one another so to the
american viewers like or you know the
people in north america around the world
michael mcintyre is our seinfeld he is
you know he is the main man
the phenomenal comedian and that's bbc
one that's prime time that's the dream
i'm going to do stand-up comedy
on michael mcintyre's big show so i'm
walking out
thinking yeah how do i act surprised
when he tells me because i think this is
pretty much nailed on yeah and then and
then he says you know 20 minutes ago
you've got
a photograph went up online of of you
kissing casual uh outside a pub so
[Music]
their life
life flips and um and you don't do
michael mcintyre's big show
you do trigonometry
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
fantastic british comedian sean walsh
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much thank you for having me i didn't
know where to look when you were doing
that bit yeah you were talking to the
camera yeah what there's some people
watching no i know but where do i look
look at that
no i know i look at you now yeah but i
didn't know what to do when you were
looking at that yeah
what do people do normally do when
you're doing that bit watch you do that
yeah
right i felt uncomfortable do you want
to do it again no no i really don't want
to do it again i started looking at the
poster i was like maybe i should just
look around the room okay but we're fine
now we're fine now okay good good to
have you on man so
we've got a big international audience
so for them you you're
you had you've had a great mainstream
career you were in all the big comedy
shows in this country mock the week yeah
live with the apollo
10 cats and now you're here so you've
done [ __ ] up my brother
no this is the peak this is the pig this
is what we're all aiming for
um
so how did so let's just for people who
don't know you just tell a little bit
about your story you know growing up
getting into comedy why i'm here that's
how i've ended up here exactly
that is exactly the question so god been
doing comedy now for 15 years yeah
always wanted to be comedian was doing
stand-up in like the playground as a kid
lovely evans all of that stuff it's all
i ever really wanted to do and uh i've
now been doing it professionally as i
say for 15 years and was very lucky did
all the big shows and uh you had a lot
of early success didn't you
i suppose i i suppose i did it's weird
you don't you don't you don't say that
about your yourself
you said it about me and you but you
also don't
i think as i've gotten older i've got a
bit more comfortable with it and you can
look back retrospectively and go
oh god i think i was what i was doing
was kind of that was quite extraordinary
for someone in their mid-twenties to be
doing those things early twenties early
yeah early mid twenty kind of twenty
three and not to keep interrupting you
but the week back then was very
different to mark the week now you had a
way bigger audience i remember
when i'd
when i did this when i did the first
time i did mock the week it went out
when i was at the edinburgh festival and
i think i was either 23 or 24
and i was doing what any 23 24 year old
you know was doing i was getting
completely shit-faced and i got on when
mock the week went out my first ever
like you say it was the days of frankie
boyle uh i went out the night the night
before so i went out the night it went
out and then i was locked out and the
flat we had was on what's one of the
main roads in edinburgh that crosses the
bridge like nielsen street yeah
that was in nicholson street i was
locked out and i fell asleep
outside the front door
nicholson street using bin bags as
pillows
and people were stepping over me to go
to work
what must they have been thinking like
that's the guy from mock the week
[Laughter]
he's homeless
so yes i was very i was very
young and i was doing those things and
then
fast forward
uh did strictly come dancing which in
america is dancing with the stars
and uh three weeks in got um
three weeks quite famously got
undermarked with my pasado
hmm that was one of the things that
happened
i do think we were undermarked no i got
photographed someone
um very kindly photographed me and my
dance partner kissing and i was in a
relationship and she was married yeah
and that so that was three over three
years ago now and there was quite the
there was quite well you were on the
front page of the sun which is the
biggest tabloid in this country as far
as i know for 12 days in a row i think
it was 12 days yeah
what was that like just going from
because
i mean
you were nailing it well you know for
the first few weeks you know you were
doing i was having the time of my life
he was smashing it and you know it was
all you know i think i genuinely think
we were i mean i know this is not what
you you you got me here for but i think
we were on the mark for the tango and
under march of the pasado play and i'm
saying that i'm putting it out there no
it was going really really well it was
it was it
look
you
you kind of
you get into comedy i don't know what
you guys got into this for but i got
into it i wanted i wanted to make people
laugh and i wanted to make as many
people laugh as i as i possibly could
and now i was on the biggest show on
television
and people seemed you know people seemed
to to like me and i was having fun i was
i was dancing i was doing this thing
that no one expected me to to do it's
not the kind of thing if you've seen my
act or you know me you wouldn't
associate me with a show like that but i
was having the time of my life and it
and it was yeah who knows what
what would have happened had uh or where
you know how far that that we would have
got and it's one of the few shows that's
still on television has a huge audience
so if you come across well and people
like you
you're going to be touring to you stop
stop reminding me
[Laughter]
you've done you've done a special about
that thing so i'm kind of taking you
through some of the stuff you talk about
because this was the dream right yes and
then three weeks in
you know this thing's happened you get
caught essentially yes it is
photographed and then your agent taps
you on the shoulder goes can we just pop
outside i've got something to tell you
you go there and and specifically i
think it kind of heightens the drama and
you know 95 well i'm joking in the show
it's clear that i'm joking but
everything else is is really what
happened uh he says is the right to have
a word of view outside we've just
finished the pasado on saturday night
live on on television
and you know to millions of people and
we've i've got through i'm so happy
and uh and he says kind of a word of you
outside
and i think he's going to tell me that
i've been booked for michael mcintyre's
big show on bbc one another so to the
american viewers like or you know the
people north america around the world
michael mcintyre is our seinfeld he is
you know he is the main man and the
phenomenal comedian and that's bbc one
that's prime time that's the dream i'm
going to do stand-up comedy
on
michael mcintyre's big show so i'm
walking out
thinking yeah how do i act surprised
when he tells me because i think this is
pretty much nailed on yeah and then he
says as i say in the show he says you
know 20 minutes ago you've got
a photograph went up online of of you
kissing casual uh outside a pubs so
their life
life flips and um and you don't do
michael mcintyre's big show
you do trigonometry
but um
it's it's nice to be able to kind of
i'll say this and you know i don't know
where this this interview is going to go
but
doing that doing that show people the
assumption people make and even have
made about that show is that it was
it would seem as if it would be
cathartic
and i think it was kind of cathartic on
the on the first few goes yeah you do
that show you tell your story and i told
it i pretty much that i think i was
doing that show
up to like kind of like i don't know
four months after it happened or three i
wrote it in a month i went to l.a wow
because i and and not to be showbiz i
went away because i i couldn't write it
here it was you know i couldn't get here
i couldn't
well i know that feeling you're walking
around thinking that person has looked
at me do they know me like it's it's
really uncomfortable
it's horrific it's really horrific so
you're sitting on yeah you're sitting on
the tube and someone gives you a look
and it's oh god they hate me that's not
you're not gonna be able to write a show
in that no not in that state of mind so
i went away
but
so i came back and it worked people
seemed to be laughing at the show
and he felt like wow
and there was this kind of self-con
pronunciation congratulations
congratulations yeah no that wasn't it
no
you're self-congratulated
it's contagious
congratulatory
okay i was impressed with myself
but it it
you then had to
repeat this story every night on tour
yeah and then take it to edinburgh and
repeat what was at the time
the most horrific thing i'd ever
been through and hoped that i ever go
through and repeat that every night and
people were laughing it was it was oh
god there were there were periods where
in edinburgh where i was like they would
laugh and there'd be a moment where i'd
turn around and i'd have my back to the
crowd and i'd just be turning around and
going
[Laughter]
but what was so nice
about the recording is it was three
years afterwards and it kind of
heightens the how ludicrous
the whole thing was
and actually i had a lot of fun doing
the show so it's really nice that the
recording of the show was actually
enjoyable for me i really loved doing it
whereas if we had recorded
the show in in the heat of it
you would have had a man pretending that
he wanted to be there and i did i didn't
want to be there what's it like being in
the heat of that in the in the eye of
that media storm
what does that like to pick up an
edition of the sun or the copy of the
sun and your face is on the front cover
with some ridiculous headlines that must
have been awful
well
i think these things are a lot more
pernicious than you expect so
you kind of emotionally
deteriorate
did it
deteriorate
and and
but at the time there's too much
adrenaline yeah to actually take in
what's happening you're not you don't
see the front page and go this is awful
you kind you can't you can't believe
what it is that you're going through
you're just you're in shock to be honest
yeah and and and what i thought was
maybe interesting
as a show
was that i was now living you know like
you see the tabloids i don't read the
tabloids but whenever i see the tabloids
it's usually going into a petrol station
on tour and they're out in those boxes
those weird boxes with the clear screens
and you have a glance yeah you have a
glance and you carry on with your life
and you never think about that thing
that you've glanced at ever again and
suddenly i was the thing
that that you glance out and never think
about again
and yeah i was gonna have to think about
this every day forever
the distance between glancing at that
story and being in that story was so
massive
that i i i was i can't believe that
thing that i got so it feels like this
so when you've just glanced at that that
story whatever it is you're like oh my
god that person's
that person's whole life has has
collapsed
and it's just something that i go
and now i'm bit i'm being that yeah and
and i thought that maybe
i was like do people no do people know
that that story they're glancing at is
like
is is the destruction of someone's life
do they know that and i thought they
probably don't because i didn't and i
thought that's what i thought maybe that
will be this that'll be the show i'll
kind of go because not you know it
doesn't normally it's not normally a
stand-up comedian that's centered to
those stories
so i strangely i kind of unique uniquely
have an opportunity to kind of tell this
story which most people if you were a
singer all right you might write a song
but it you're not going to be able to
capture the
that nuance and that kind of
perhaps that trauma in a in a song
in three minutes but i'll have an hour
to kind of demonstrate what this was
this was like
it
it was just it was a kind of outer body
experience unless i don't
you look at the
it was the you know you got the physical
paper itself which i didn't really ever
see by the way i saw the first one on
that on that sunday
um i did see that when i i popped into a
shop but after that i never really saw
the front coat it was all on the it was
all on the internet and um
it was just were you able to switch off
because i had something on a smaller
scale but like i know your phone is
filled up with [ __ ]
journalists going oh can we get
messages and twitter is going mental and
all of that were you able to switch off
from that or was that no
i mean
you know i'm much obviously it's been
three years i'm
i'm much better than i i uh that i was
but i mean it was
i'd been kind of traumatized by the
whole thing it was it was all i thought
about on
on just a constant
basis like
we would be talking and then maybe if
you left and i was on my own it would
just go back to that and i would relive
all of the tweets and i would relive all
of the things that people had said about
me and it just echoed it couldn't sleep
at night it would just it would just be
there it was by the way i should say
sometimes when i end up talking about
this
publicly what happened the response to
it a lot of the time unfortunately is
look at him he's now playing the victim
i'm not playing the vic i'm just i'm
being asked a question of what it was
like i'm telling you what the punishment
felt like yeah and there'll be people
that go good i mean i've had people say
good i'm glad you you went through that
but
and fine you know whatever but but i'm
just i'm not i have to be clear i'm not
it's very important i'm not looking for
sympathy you've got to come you've got
to enter a place in your life where
you've got to try and not care about
what people you and so hard especially
with what we do because you're trying to
go on stage and
you want people to like what you said
laugh and like you and have a good time
you you know like i say in the show
what happened was the opposite of what i
was looking for i didn't want people to
to hate me so
what it's done is it's it's kind of made
me try and
build this wall which i'm not doing very
well of not caring what people think so
i'm not looking for anyone's sympathy
you know i
i've got to not care what what they
think which is hard it's really hard
because you
you just want people i mean i don't know
the problem is i'm now at the stage in
my life where i know
you know i mainly know comedians i'm
that guy
and so we
we are actually we've got a thing where
we we want to go up and be liked it's
really odd
and men quite frankly mentally
but i don't know if you know that would
apply to someone that didn't do comedy
would you go do you just i think people
just want to be liked don't they yeah of
course tonight's lovely they're really
nice like you know people go i like you
guys
lovely
you love it you know it happens
[Laughter]
but let me ask you this because look my
wife and i met when we were 18. been
together since
so i am exactly the sort of person that
will judge you for what happens yes
right
but you joke about it in the show you
say look guys it's been three years and
i think i can say this you overreacted
and it's presented in a beautiful joke
and it's funny thank you and i would say
even as the type of person that would
normally judge you i mean the reaction
to what happened wasn't and this isn't
again this isn't about making you play
the victim or no yeah but but it was
absurd wasn't it
look look at the prime minister of this
country right the prime minister an
elected politician keeps cheating on his
wives and whatever
and he's the prime minister
yeah
can you say that will that have to get
cut
and here's a comedian yeah
look it's not morally the right thing to
do
but was that the proportion that
responds to what happened well like
the thing is
is
you know obviously i i went through it
so
yeah totally
there's a bit of bias here yeah no uh
in terms of i think in terms of what
i think in terms of what the tabloids
decided to write
you're
you you you know you sign a contract
don't you with the devil as you you go
i'm gonna go on the biggest show on on
television and it's a and it's you know
it's kind of it's a family show isn't it
i mean obviously
we didn't do that on the show
it was outside i mean that would have
yes
think of the ratings
but you know outside of
the show and
um
and
there was a photo as well you know
everyone says that about
you know people you know people have
done this before and people have done
worse but they don't
they didn't have a photo right you know
can you imagine what these journalists
it's like the matt hancock thing there
was a video yeah yeah and so that makes
it that in a corridor though cctv wasn't
it yeah yeah that makes it that much
worse the little ass crab and all that
you know it adds it adds flavor
and what did i do
we have a photo of sean
don't make me
we have the photo here
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
i've never thought about that but the
photo you think is part of why it went
as big as it did
right no of course right right of course
and i
i
honestly by the way i'm not this isn't a
kind of change of heart this is
the the tabloids
what you have to
realize is
although i had done all these stand-up
shows
i don't think the public you know i
wasn't a kind of bbc one
face
the public didn't really know
who i was they might say they knew my
name they knew the girl the guy with the
long hair and the nasally voice the
really irritating voice
it sounds like he smokes 40 a day him
like they didn't actually know who i was
so what you do then
is your whole personality and your whole
identity is up for grabs
because anyone can write anything about
you because this is now how the public
can find public are going to find out
about you they've got no preconception
they can't go i don't know about that i
don't reckon he's like that i watched
him i watched him on a documentary and
he kind of seemed like a nice guy you
know the way you have a familiarity with
say anton deck for example you kind of
you've got that thought that warm
saturday night you feel like you know
them so if something is written about
them
you kind of got this this judgment that
you can make about the person i don't
know
i'm not sure i buy that
you
the only information you were getting
about me as a person as a human being
was through what was being written about
me
that
so what do you what are people expected
to do if they this guy has cheated on uh
his girlfriend
he's kissed his dance partner's
photograph
and then every article is about how much
of a [ __ ] is
well
there was no there was no opposing
there was no opposition to that what a
moment am i meant to come out and tweet
no no hang on
sorry i know i know i did that but
actually i'm a nice guy i can't do that
and there was there was going to be
no journalist that was going to do that
for me
so the tabloids are running that story
if you get caught
kissing your dance partner this is what
will happen so we could talk about it
was blown out of proportion
but i was on the biggest show and you
could give all the things going on
in the world how comes that you're on
the front page for 12 days doing this
well because it's it's it's celebrity
culture this is what people find
interesting maybe not you and i
but this is what
this is what people like seemingly
evidently
i'm into we're into people's
private lives and if and what is there
anything more fun than reading about how
much of a [ __ ] someone is
absolutely not
so people are going like
he's
and every photo i mean they did
you know they did manipulate my my
personality a lot and
they kind of did you know they they
really went they really zoned in on the
alcohol which i felt
at the time i felt was unfair but
you know i did bloody love to drink not
drunk now in a long time i did love a
drink but they would just get pictures
of me
like you know
just sat outside a cafe and then they
would they would scream they kind of get
that that snapshot when you're you're
blinking
so then so then the shot is just this
with
[Music]
um and i wasn't really doing anything
that that you know anyone in my kind of
position or age would have you know i
went out and i was good at i mean i had
too much of a good time that's that's
for sure but
but
i don't it wasn't that it wasn't the
table it wasn't the ta
believe it or not it wasn't really
yes i felt like i was being attacked
naturally you're good you know if
everyone keeps writing about you it's
[ __ ] terrifying if you've never been
for anything like it it was more i think
probably what
hurt more was
just everyone not everyone but
it felt like
i felt like there wasn't much
do i want to say not defense of me but
just was it a loss of control you felt
sean in that we all cultivate our image
do you know what i mean yes totally yeah
so we cultivate our image especially
comics yeah you know we go out and and
you've got the allotted time to go
this is what i'm like and and yeah i've
completely lost that control and
everyone else was deciding who i was
uh yeah it was absolutely that that i
suppose that
strange
loss of control because you do have a
control in real life when you
you meet people there's an element of
control that you have of you you want if
you i want this per i want to get on
with this person i will and maybe not
necessarily consciously but i will be
this version of myself
if you don't like someone you know i i
tell you now you could meet two you can
me i always think
but someone was saying to me uh
i worked i i worked on a sitcom
with jack d it was wonderful it was like
dream come true stuff i was injecting
sitcom and um
i was recently with someone on it and he
was he was so nice he was talking about
you know how enthusiastic i was and and
kind of saying how nice
it was to work with me like we all had
an amazing time i had such i was in such
a good place i was in jack d sitcom
i mean that is the dream and
and then i thought that's so weird
because and i said to him no no i'm not
it's really funny you keep saying how
cheerful i am i'm i'm not cheerful i was
having a good
you've got cheer for me because i was
having a great time and going you could
talk to someone that worked with me on a
thing where i wasn't enjoying myself
yeah you'd be talking about
two completely different human beings
you'd be going there's no i know sean
she was nothing like that there's yeah
there are different shapes and sizes to
all of us
so it was it was so strange to just
completely lose like you're saying all
of that
hey constantine do you like shopping no
in russia you skin bear with your bare
hands and wear it obviously this is for
men only women and small children are
allowed to use knife where did you get
your blazer from it's made out of bear
babushka created it for me using nothing
but her own bare hands no pun intended i
wondered what the smell was but for
those of you who do want an easy no
hassle solution to the grind of going
shopping then stitch fix is for you
stitch fix is a service for both men and
women and make shopping for clothes easy
to get started go to stitch fix dot co
dot uk forward slash trigger to set up
your profile they'll deliver clothes
chosen just for you in your taste size
and budget and by taste they mean
something that will look good instead of
showing the world you're having a
mid-life crisis like me the items you
buy arrive at your door a few days later
you try everything on at home decide
what to keep and then send anything else
back it's so easy you just pay 10 pounds
each time you order which is credited
towards the items you keep and you'll
get 20 off when you keep all five items
there's no subscription plus shipping
returns and exchanges are easy and free
stitch fix does the hard work for you
making shopping for clubs easy and
hassle free get started today at
stitchfix dot co dot uk forward slash
trigger and get 20 off when you keep all
five items can you order fresh siberian
bear skin from stitch fix
possibly go to stitch fix dot co dot uk
forward slash trigger to find out
and then there was a reaction that you
had which was a physical reaction which
was the opening to the special which is
actually
i mean you present it in a comedic
manner and it is funny but it's also
it's [ __ ] awful well i after that it
ended up
triggering a lot of
i had a lot i had a lot of panic attacks
after that
really really bad i did panic attacks in
my early 20s but that was mainly just
to chain smoking
10 cups of black coffee a day
jager bombs at night
yeah i didn't know what caffeine did
yeah and
i just
in my early 20s like
having panic attacks and and then going
to the doctors and then going so how
much coffee did you say
about 10 cups of coffee yeah it's like
yeah i don't think you should be doing
that that's that's what's bringing on
the panic attacks but cut two
coming out of that there was a physical
reaction
it was just
i still get them occasionally
when
something in my head triggers and takes
me back to it all
i just feel overwhelmed and yeah you
have a physical kind of
everything spins and you kind of
collapse it's it's very it's a it's
horrific but
you know
i don't i like what i hope that no one
was
i hope that was no one's goal that's
just yeah that was just me being i'm not
i'm not someone that's really built for
i think i think there are people there
are comedians right
now that exist that seem to
um thrive
off
like conflict
on the internet
you know that people say bad things
about them and they thrive off it and
they go off here talking about me mate
is it you do you i i can't do that we
really do you you're frightened i have
the hatred oh yes one hates me this is
fantastic
no i i just i don't i just go oh god
someone hates me this is absolutely yeah
but i think it's a good point i think i
never wanted to be like john that's the
difference what are you joking no i
never wanted to be like what do you mean
i never wanted to be liked well i i
don't i don't care if you like me i i
care if what i'm saying is true or if
it's funny or if it's well written and
if you don't like it no one's going to
laugh at your thing if they don't like
you no they will
there's no i don't
no think about it in life it's forget
comedy we're at an event we're at a
gathering someone you hate saturday oh
true that person says something funny
you there's no way you're laughing
that's a good correction so what i mean
all about jack d said back on what he
did uh i never forget it i just started
and i watched jack on mark lawson on bbc
four and jack d said comedy is eighty
percent likeable yeah likability you're
right that never left me you're right
the look at this look at this look at
someone like rob beckett yeah i love rob
to [ __ ] look at like he's a brilliant
comedian but look
look
you just love him
i've been in his company he's just a
great guy to be around making people
laugh
that's that's
here's here's where i think we're
talking past each other i think you're
exactly right no no no you're exactly
right we're just having the conversation
online though there's a difference
between because
very often the things that make some
people really really
also
like
you
do so online yeah right right are also
the thing that makes some people really
really hate you okay so if i'm online
making a joke that's articulating the
point of view of
80 of the population in a funny way
and 20
of the population really really really
hate that yes that's where you end up
right
and i have no problem with the 20 hating
me if i'm articulating something in a
funny way that makes people laugh and
and people feel that their point of view
about the world is being validated by
somebody who's got an audience it's also
dependent as well on the style of comedy
that you do for example exactly yes
i i talk about microwaves yeah yeah i
was always quite political and satirical
in what i did yeah yeah yeah so if
you're going to tackle a subject that is
contentious that gets people head up
whatever it may be and you tackle it and
it may be a brilliant routine there's
people going to be oh it's punching down
this is disgraceful you can't say that
you're laughing yeah xyz yeah whereas if
you're doing a brilliant routine about
microwaves
yeah most people aren't going to get
that reaction although there will always
be a couple yeah yeah yeah
don't take issues
this is why i asked you about
proportionality because one of the
things we've explored on the show is you
know people
uh who've got cancelled for a joke or
who got canceled for saying the wrong
thing i've got and it certainly feels to
me like
in the command climate people are being
we're having disproportionate reactions
to things that people say and do right
whereas you got can you got 90s
cancelled for like an old school 90s 90s
council you know like that's what people
used to get cancelled for yeah yeah
well
like i i knew you know i knew we were
gonna we were gonna a brush on the topic
of
of cancer culture but i mean i'm not
trying to lead you to any party
oh god no no no no don't worry about
that no it's fine
no but i
the thing is i joke i say i'm cancelled
in the show and i think that you know
after after
strictly come dancing
after the kiss you
uh
you
if if if
it's the entertainment business guys you
know they're gonna like you you can
and if everything that has been written
about you
is pointing to people in the direction
that well we don't like this and i think
there's i think i've always just as a
person
kind of suffered with that i think look
you know kind of long hair looked
confident was never confident but looked
confident it was kind of
people didn't i don't think i was
i always remember remember being really
envious of josh whitaker
um great comic but you know that
you just loved just just
being in a room people just just took to
josh
just warm
and
so
so likeable you know and then and then i
and the lion was there just kind of
miserable and hung over and
when i was younger lent myself to
to being
to kind of being disliked i think i was
just a kind of dislikable
i tell you what it is for me like i
remember when i started in comedy and
you're already on the ascendancy you're
this young good-looking guy who would
come out and just crush gigs just crush
gigs and then there'd be because for the
rest of us it took us time to find out
what we wanted to do yeah but you seem
to come out fully formed i remember
paul ricketts saying the first time he
ever saw your gig it was like your 10th
gig and he said i don't know what is it
is but sean had it i think i'd know i
think hey when i was started out yeah i
i could there's been enough time since
now and then that i think that
i was
i think i was yeah i think i i i look i
had been studying i i'm not joking i was
it's in the show i was doing stand-up in
the playground i didn't do homework at
school teachers put their homework down
and i would say it's okay i'm gonna be a
film star i wouldn't do the homework i
thought i was gonna be jim carrey that
was my upset i just thought
i'm gonna be a comedian i don't need to
know i mean it's really not helped i'm
thinking [ __ ]
i know nothing because i just
was just all i wanted to do was be a
comedian yeah and so when i started
people go this guy's is this only his
10th gig no no you don't understand
i
this is all i thought about like robin
williams talked about that there's a few
other comics just as 10 year olds they
were practicing eight hours a day
in the mirror yeah right see this i
don't think i do this do i do this in
the show do i watch it recently yeah
yeah well you know that's with the
eyebrows no i don't think you did that
so yeah i think i cut out we not only
had an hour i was when i first saw
acentura would go into in the mask
which i i think only released in uh
like a year apart um doing that with the
the eyebrows i would go in so easy now
just comes to me i couldn't do that i
would as a kid 10 year old in the mirror
would put both eyebrows up hold one down
and just do this oh just so that there
was just one eyebrow and then do it with
the other and that was hours and hours
in front of the mirror training to do
that with my eyebrow like i so
i had it wasn't my tenth gig it i've
been in my head i've been doing this
forever and i would go to the comedia
the local comedy club in brighton every
sunday on my own the bouncers begin to
the bouncers would i would turn up and
it would be that weird kid
that was coming to the club every year
every sunday on his own they just
started letting me in yeah yeah that's
how i go oh it's you yeah don't worry
about it just walk in
but i think what happened was
this
this is so strange thinking back over my
career
where i did get a lot
quite early on a lot of television i
think it it did me a lot of but and
again i'm sound like i'm being very
ungrateful i'm not ungrateful it's some
amazing some of the things i've done
i think it was probably too much for me
to to handle at such a young age and i
think it destroyed a lot of my
confidence
it destroyed a lot i i suddenly i
i hadn't
i was so mad right it was just naivety
it wasn't even arrogance it was i
suppose it was when you were younger
i literally just thought like
i'm like i'm gonna i'll have a sitcom i
thought i was thought i'll i've had this
thought and then
then i started doing tv and i was
way out on my death
well i'm not doing stand-up but doing
like the panel show i didn't know what
the [ __ ] i was doing
and suddenly
the doubt comes in
and i never really doubted myself before
and then when you first get that doubt i
don't know i've i'm not just saying
because people go oh
but when
we were doing when those first three
weeks are strictly
i felt like i did at the beginning of my
stand-up career and i felt like i've got
it back
and i'm it's
this is it right and
that because that doubt in my that i
kind of developed in my mid-20s that and
i think that's why i drank a lot as well
i think i really
i just suddenly like i couldn't really
hand i felt like
at such a young age [ __ ] i won't name
him because he was saying privately but
there's a friend of ours he's not a
lovely young comic he's been going since
he was a [ __ ] you know 18 he's one of
these guys
so he's only 25 now i'm with him he's
talking about regret he's talking about
the mistakes he's made and i'm like it
hurts me so much i'm like man
you can't you're 25. like you've not
made you've not made any mistakes
they're steps they're stick come on
like because i was there i was 25
[ __ ] years of age going i [ __ ] it
i've ruined it i've completely ruined
and it's
i just wish that i hadn't i wish i'd
handled that better kind of got myself
up dusting myself down come on and i i
really it ain't me a a lot see a lot of
people are watching this and they've
seen panel shows on tv yeah yeah and the
thing that is created is very very
different from what actually happens
yeah yeah yeah
what was it like doing that and thinking
i'm not doing well here oh god [ __ ]
it looks just like
man i did a show
i did a show i had my own tv show on
comedy central called sean walsh world
and um
it was an internet clip show
and
i did this show and it was just like
the time
this was before trolling
the the phrase trolling
this is another straight hold you i'm 39
you're 39 36 39 39 right
so when we how long have you been going
uh i i did it for about five years i
haven't done it since the pandemic okay
wow so we do comedy here we write your
anxieties down isn't it nice
i'm loving it
the traveling for me it was the travel
action
for me was the travel yeah that i when
the pandemic started and the lockdown
came i was like i loved lockdown
yeah oh my god yeah i bet you did
yeah yeah yeah that was lovely yes yeah
but
yeah
um sean can i come back though of course
no no but it's great all i was gonna say
this is what my point was gonna be i
don't think i don't i don't i i joke
about being cancelled yeah i still sin
strictly yeah i've done bits and bobs on
telly i've not been and i tore and so
i've not been cancelled but but did it
make it harder for me you just went down
away i lost the
you gotta own what you did and you gotta
process that and you gotta learn from
that and you're gonna grow from that i
don't know that you've done that yeah
right yeah so i'm not trying to get you
to say oh i was cancelled i know you're
i was treated so badly yeah yeah yeah i
know you're just
you you've got to be a man and own it
because that you [ __ ] up and then the
consequences inevitably are on you yes
however yeah however right i'm talking
about broader society right the broader
culture yeah do we want to live in a
society where someone does what you did
or someone makes a bad joke or someone
says the wrong thing or someone you know
is slightly insensitive about a minority
group that now we're very focused on and
then people
who they've been working with for five
10 15 years suddenly go oh you know what
you're untouchable now
is that the society that we we should be
living in is what i'm getting at
okay yeah so but should be living in or
are do you think we are living in that
we're definitely not living in a society
where people are forgiven for mistakes
they make
right
would you disagree well
well actually you know and believe it or
not i i because i thought when i was
coming i was like [ __ ] you know i don't
i don't think about this kind of stuff i
was gonna say enough but it's not enough
i just yeah
i don't really have these discussions
outside of this but i would when i hear
that question i think
forgiveness takes time
forget you know like
you know you can't if someone's done
something wrong you can't
you can't just do something wrong and
and then go oh we've got to forgive him
people [ __ ] up let's crack on you know i
think i think you've got a
there are um
have we got any examples i mean me
for example yeah me as an example right
i'm having to do that
um i'm i i've recently did catherine
ryan's new stand-up show let's get out
on amazon and that wouldn't have
happened
uh six months after strictly no way
you'd go [ __ ] off without having him on
the show yeah
but we have time i think people
people go i think i think he's learned
his lesson hasn't he and
and and now i'm kind of slowly getting
work again and and it's it's really
things are going really going really
well i just think they they take time i
don't know of anyone that's been
you know is that is there an example of
anyone that's done something that where
they haven't kind of been forgiven or
let
lawrence yeah alistair williams chris
mcglade i mean i can keep going
there's a lot of people but
bill cosby
there you go
but louis c.k
not defending any of these people i know
you're not defending now i know you're
not and bill cosby was a joke to be
clear right yeah but
i'm saying it for them
because it'll be someone going yeah
okay right but
the other and look louis ck yeah but
does that does that mean his career
should be ruined forever but hang on it
goes it's like it's not he i mean he's
released two specials that you can pay
for and watch on the internet yeah i
imagine he's making hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars off
yeah so all right like he's laughing
isn't he yeah well that's a little bit
different because has he still got the
same career that he had before
does does does he still sells out all
those massive rooms doesn't he but this
is what the conversation is really about
for me it's like people will say and and
perhaps there's some truth to it that if
you get cancelled and you make a big
stink about it what you can benefit from
it right people will say that and i
think if you play your cards right that
is true
that is true you can because i'm the
cancelled guy yeah yeah yeah and that's
definitely true there's definitely an
element to that but
there's also other people for whom
that's really not true who who really uh
never recover from that and and i've
given you an example of a few now chris
mcglade for example i don't know if you
know anything about him
no i don't he's a sort of uh anyway we
weren't getting the scottish guy uh he's
northern same thing
okay
yeah so basically he had a poem in the
show which said something about the
rothschilds and it happened to have been
a bad moment for race relations and then
he had all the shows cancelled from the
theater and the only reason he's still
even gigging and maybe the only he was
suicidal right yeah he came on this show
and he got a few of our fans supporting
him and now he's got a tour and he's
coming back on the show soon to talk
about it so that's worked out for him
but that's
what's happened to him is massively
disproportionate to the crime and that's
what i'm getting at right yeah well
sean again i'm not trying to get you to
say anything that you don't believe
honest no i'm just that that uh inhaler
is just me trying to is me trying to
kind of form a
an opinion immediately i think
it is
the outrage always feels
disproportionate but
that that's
this is where we are now with with
social media
the the
the outpour is is always going to be
massive
i mean i don't really under i don't
i don't think
it's got it's gossiping isn't it it's
people that it's people gossiping
talking to strangers it's a
foreign forum of of rumors and and
outrage and opinions
he was what he was removed because
his shows were pulled i don't know the
same show that he did at that same
theater a year previously to rave
reviews suddenly now is too problematic
right uh but look we're going down a bit
no but i'm sorry it's just because i
don't it's because i don't
it's because i don't i don't understand
yeah i don't really understand why
that's
that's happened to him like but i don't
know the story and i and but all i can
do is i can
the bit that i can identify with is how
awful that must have been for him yeah
to go for parents and i think i think
what's what can be tough is
is you know no one you know you don't
you know like
look at jimmy yeah jimmy carr went
jimmy made that joke the 3 000 people in
the room
laughed i mean you know he doesn't
if he knows he can't tell the future if
he knows that that's going to be if what
the reaction was going to be was going
to happen does he do that joke probably
probably doesn't do that joke so
it's so tough we live in a world where
you don't know what the reaction's gonna
be how can you no you know he didn't
know that was that when jimmy made that
joke he didn't know that was the line
that line hadn't been drawn so he makes
the joke and then they go
no that you crossed the line it's like
[ __ ] the line wasn't there
the [ __ ] lie wasn't it [ __ ] i didn't
know that you told me that was the line
before i would have said it so it's
it's it is it is tough i don't may i ask
one more question
so this is the brilliant point that
you've made about jimmy and the line
right because to me the healthy attitude
of society to comedy has always been
look comedians are going to make
mistakes all the time
right
yeah you're going to make a joke
and we're constantly feeling where that
line is right in a room in a room
yeah or or when you're doing something
on on youtube or whatever like we do
right you're constantly going where is
this line let's feel it out let's see if
we can cross it what happens here but i
feel that we've got to a position where
it's like the moment you get past the
line it's no longer oh that that was
you know how people used to go in the
comedy club
and that was it and you're okay that's a
bit far yeah but dude that's the comedy
club the pro the pro the reason that
none of this can be kind of none of this
can be
in one of more of a a better kind of
sentence basically is calmed down and
the reason that can't happen is because
it's leaving the comedy club and it's
going on to say 7 a.m on good morning
britain it's just look it can't you you
can't resolve this the thing you can
control is what is what happens in
in the room right that could be but you
don't control that anymore because
you've got people with phones and all
that [ __ ] right
so i just i don't i don't think this
stops i think it just gets worse
it just it just carries on and gets and
gets worse and you have to kind of live
a bit i mean i listened to i listened to
tommy tiernon talking to adam buxton a
few months ago
and they were talking about i think a
joke that tommy got in trouble for uh
about jewish people i think it was i
think it was
and
and adam buxton
had suggested maybe
that comedians now need
to
not just think about because like my
the defense would always be like but are
you listening to what i mean because
this what happens when it goes onto the
internet people interpret everything and
the way they just interpret things and
they go well i think he means that why
don't you actually think about what
he or she is trying to say as opposed to
your interpretation of what what are
they actually just trying to say and
then we'll just go with that because
they didn't mean anyone any harm right
this is what they were trying to say but
adam buxton was and that's always been
my kind of line but yeah i don't think
he really meant to hurt
anyone's feelings
but with
adam boxing suggested that maybe now we
need to take into account
the
what it could
be perceived as and i thought oh god
that's interesting
see by the way this doesn't touch any of
the stand up i do my stand up now you
know so so this is why i don't think
about it that much yeah
microwave stuff doesn't get microwave
stuff what am i writing about i've got a
dog you know and and and and people stop
you when you have a dog and they go is
it a boy or a girl and you think why did
you want to [ __ ] it that's why that's
all i'm talking about i'm not talking
about the issues
but
i mean you could go then into the trans
stuff from the boy or girl but
he does the dog
but because i don't think about that
stuff yeah but here's the point yeah
right what something could be perceived
as isn't that just the death of comedy
isn't that just you second and third and
fourth guessing every piece of material
that you write if you start to think
well hang on well then that could be
perceived as this but it could also be
perceived as anything now i'm someone
with anxiety i perceive a billion
different things at the same [ __ ]
time yeah that's why i'm crippled some
of the time you can't operate like that
well
but the the room yeah you see what i try
to not think past the room i'm playing
with you and the room will let you know
oh yeah you know but that's how always
that's all i'm saying man that's how it
always was you are in the room you do a
joke the audience pulls back you go that
was too far for this audience in this
room yeah i'll try it again by the way i
do when i'm trying new stuff i do i i do
sometimes say things where the crowd
goes like oh would you go oh okay maybe
not that yeah and you maybe try it again
you change the wording you play around
with it and eventually if it's a [ __ ]
bit or if it's too offensive you drop it
yeah that's how it was but if every time
you go too far
then suddenly the world descends upon
you and ruins your life that is going to
affect your comedy isn't it
i i imagine it will yeah yeah yeah
that's all we're talking about no i know
it is but i know i know i know it is but
i think
but i think
if
it's just
you have to you know the audience isn't
one thing the public we call it the
public yeah the audience it's not one
thing it's made of individuals and and
each staff every time you do a re do a
room
there's a different people in that room
that are going to give you a lot of the
time there might be a different reaction
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to create a um
you know you're trying to create a
consistency aren't you preferably going
into every room and smashing every room
and that's generally impossible even for
the the biggest and the best
but you you know you each each gig is
different and like the audience will
they'll let you know what they're what
they're up for that night and i i don't
i mean could tom
tommy
now does he have to think about what it
might be perceived as but you respond i
suppose your responsibility changes
doesn't it the bigger you are it doesn't
matter what
doesn't matter what an open spot is is
saying but tommy tin and then what
happens is this weird thing happens
that's always been the way is that if
you become a huge name suddenly you're
given like you guys with this you know
this has grown suddenly you're given
this responsibility where people
suddenly expect things from you
and
and that that's just that's just always
been the way
and what's it like to have that
responsibility
does it mean that suddenly you start
second guessing third guessing or do you
just have to be a comedian and go look
i'm going to say what i'm going to say i
do but i don't i don't think i've ever
had that i i was in the limelight which
meant it mattered what i not mattered
but you know what i mean it was what i
was saying was going to be picked up but
it wasn't um it's not like
it's not like people are generally
speaking coming to me about you know for
my opinion about everything that's like
a different yeah yeah it's a different
game that's a different level like you
know when like when football managers
start getting asked about russia and
ukraine yeah
suddenly it's like what what's happening
but it's just
we've always been like that if you get
if you become really successful almost
at anything
suddenly you're meant to have
under actors i mean they're
actors yeah they want
actors love
people we love knowing what an actor
this guy's been an action film let's
find out what he or she thinks about
the war in in ukraine it's just always
been that way i don't know why that is
yeah yeah
hey kkk do you like podcasts no in
russia we don't have podcast all we need
are beautiful and true words of uncle
vlad to guide us and how's that working
out not good but still more trustworthy
than bbc sky cnn fox news and msnbc good
point but for those of you who do like a
funny and informative podcast then
you've got to check out the girlfriend
translator the two co-hosts to women
that answer all your questions why ask
women questions uncomflex as women are
only four because it gives men objective
advice on the minefield that is dating
and relationships in 2022 if you're
wondering why she never called you back
why she lost interest or simply how to
become a better partner then you have to
check this show out she didn't call you
back because you're not real man you
don't write bear with shot off okay mate
uh but it's not just for men ladies you
can listen and find out what makes men
tick and an insight into male psychology
there's only one answer to that
plus it's funny and you get to ask the
host questions if you've ever had a
situation in a relationship that has
left you feeling confused and want an
impartial point of view then you need to
check out the girlfriend translator
check out girlfriend translator wherever
you get your podcast i've never listened
to it because it is appropriately banned
in russia
we're all comedians and a part of being
comedian you alluded it to you to to it
yourself yeah and your show that you
wanted to be a star you wanted to be
embarrassing yeah no but it's fine it's
honest that's what was great about it
because that's what that's what we all
wanted to be when we're going in a
different type of start yeah but star
nevertheless yeah yeah but having
experienced it was it all that it was
cracked up to be
well
i don't as well well when you're in it
when you're
i don't well i do i certainly i
certainly never viewed myself as a star
but you were so you know i was i was on
television but i was recognizable
if those three weeks had run forever
yeah yeah would you have been i would
have been oh it seems like that would
have been bloody lovely
[Laughter]
like i say in the show i think like i
was walking down the street and people
are going good luck on saturday
lovely no cheers mate thank you yeah but
um
no uh and i'll tell you what's quite
funny is i and i don't i don't mention
this in the show
i only did
one
gig uh in the time that i'd been on
strictly
so in that three weeks
i did one
gig and got to feel the reaction of the
crowd they went they went nuts
it was what you dream of i went out and
the crowd were like [ __ ] it
and they went they went wild and i was
like like i say i felt like i had my
power back and i
you did an amazing
anything you say is funny flying yeah it
was amazing and uh and i did it's like a
film i got i got to experience that once
downstairs at top secret oh man
15 minutes best of the country top
secret yeah and hot water yeah
uh up in liverpool but in london yeah
top secret so um bill murray shout out
to the bill murray comedy club but the
the um yeah just once for 10 15 minutes
to feel that
to walk off
to become the number one villain yeah
for the rest of the year buddies
and that was it i got you go i felt that
once it's [ __ ] mental that's crazy
but isn't that the quintessential
celebrity experience you go from being
this here where everyone likes it
condensed into like
just three weeks
[Music]
straight down because you look at
someone like beckham david beckham he
went through the same thing where he was
just like the hero then the then in the
98 world cup everyone hated him and
that's what happens to a load of
celebrities i wonder what that did did
he ever write about what that did to him
don't if he wrote but i know he got he
needed help yeah yeah he got through
that yeah yeah yeah yeah and that was on
an even bigger scale than yours which
was gorgeous
yeah no of course
but um
what what what
i got to feel that that once
before that throughout my 20s i think i
i i'll tell you what i've learned if
you're going to go like you know it's
the film what did he learn from going
for all of that i've learnt the value of
things in my life a lot more i had no
respect i didn't value anything i had
came from
often poor background no money you know
my dad waiting for the the money to come
in
loved drugs my dad and uh
and so he'd be waiting for the the money
to come through the cash point so they
could buy his trucks
and um
and and so then
at 21 years of age
you
you you suddenly
my friends were like working remember
like gabs is working in a
in a bakery
and we're getting 127 pound 50 for 20
minutes or something 149 pound 50.
sometimes 200 quid like
it was it was mind-blowing
i had was getting paid 200 pounds to do
the thing i loved whilst my mates were
working eight hours at a bakery
like
it was unreal
so
but it meant that i didn't really learn
the vowel at such a young age when when
when people know you know in your 20s
that's when you're broke isn't it yeah
you're 20 yeah not me i wasn't broke
i i went from earning circuit money in
your early 20s which was a lot back then
to then doing tv where you're earning
like silly money
which i all spent on
ubers how much were you earning i think
i uh
well we're not going to go you know
we're talking thousands of pounds but
yeah we're talking for someone in their
20s we're talking yeah yeah you know i
didn't have to look at what a price of a
coffee was you know even a t-shirt i
should buy t i should buy a t-shirt
doesn't matter it's just like there's
only a t-shirt but to not to be at that
age where you're not looking at the va
you know the vow to not look that's such
a small thing but i wasn't looking
that's not someone that's valuing things
no
there's no values that i buy that
that's how i was with life i didn't
value anything i got from no money to
money
so i didn't have that bit which you were
meant to have in your life as a student
who then goes into work which is okay
this is how much i'm getting this week
i'm going to need this i better put this
aside get a bite this the food here some
of my friends always lived and i didn't
it wasn't i just couldn't i couldn't
connect with them i couldn't you can't
teach yourself that
if you if you suddenly be given loads of
money and you had none and you you
didn't i didn't come from
you know uh
traditional
family
that wasn't really instilled in me even
you know even if they they tried so
so you didn't learn the value of
anything when that's all taken away from
you so now you're not earning the big
bucks because you're finding it
difficult to get work and then people
everyone thinks you're a [ __ ] so they're
not coming to see your shows and that's
turned around a little bit
but suddenly
you've really got to learn
the value of
money french everything you really learn
to weigh up the value of things so when
you're talking about my 20s what was it
like i don't really know i wasn't i
wasn't i wasn't assessing this i was
just
going through it i was just getting [ __ ]
back doing it [ __ ] phase where we go
what we do there was no value and and
remember i kind of expected it weirdly
that arrogant that young i've been
wanting to do this since i was 10. so
this was what i expected of myself and
then also it wasn't really the stuff i
wanted to do i wanted to be a comic you
know jim carrey and and be doing things
like you know farcical faulty tower
style sitcoms and i was i was on panel
show it's all kind of went a bit wrong
somehow
and
it's when you reflect
and you realize god i didn't
i didn't value any of that and i didn't
value you know like i walked out the
second time i did live at the apollo the
second one so i did three times which is
amazing and the second time i did it
i bet i tell you what i was told i was
doing that and i was like oh cool
and then
i went up and i did it and i didn't even
stay and watch i think i just i
literally did my second life of the
apollo had a fantastic time
talking about jaeger bombs and being
hungover and having you know when you
have to go up uh
when you get a a
a round double decker bus and it's
packed downstairs and then you've got to
make that call
should i go upstairs
or should i stay down here and then so
you go right i'll risk it i'll see if
there's a seat upstairs and then you
have to do that walk upstairs and you
turn around and it's packed and now you
have to do the walk of shame
down the stairs where everyone is
waiting for you going yeah we know
everyone knew that was packed nice
[ __ ] yeah exactly so but i finished
that i went home and i never thought
about it again there was no appreciation
of these amazing things i was doing
whereas
obviously with what happened with
strictly everything after that there's
such an appreciation i did royal albert
hall on a tuesday
or like was it last tuesday or the
tuesday before and there's such a you
just i'm looking around like i can't
believe i'm doing this this is amazing
and you value everything
so that's been really good for me
do you know do you understand why i like
communicating
and i think i didn't have that in my 20s
there was no appreciation of [ __ ]
anything and uh it's nice to be able to
really value
my life i love my life my life my life
outside of comedy because when you're
young all of this is about comedy comedy
comedy and now i've i love my time off
stage i love my time
in west london where i live and i [ __ ] i
have a day off and i [ __ ] love it and
i never used to used to just be hungover
and go oh [ __ ] i've got a gig on shoes
oh [ __ ]
you know are you glad you went through
it
[Laughter]
i just
[Music]
it's
you you kind of want to
the hollywood answer would be yes and
you want to go like yeah maybe a better
person but i think that would have been
nicer to have had an easier route
you can't be glad you went through that
it was no you know sean i don't think
it's possible to have the life that you
had without having some kind of crash
that's true i don't know everyone thinks
that's something i don't think it was
possible because
because
that lack of presence with your life
that you talk about for the for in the
20s yeah it it was always gonna because
you you and i speak from personal
experience sure you're too arrogant
you're too arrogant
you you start to think you're everything
[Laughter]
where were you feeling this uh i was
feeling it in different things that i
was doing do you still have it
uh what the arrogance yeah
a little bit you do but it's been
tempered now do you have it
no life beat the [ __ ] at me
nice beat the living
the libertines line and i made it my
twitter bio and i actually took it down
because i thought
if if
like if i got an audition in america
which i sometimes get they might see
this and think what the [ __ ] does that
mean and then they'll look back at the
strictly stuff but um pete dotty
liberty's line which is a boy kicked out
of the world the world kicked back a lot
[ __ ] harder now yeah that that me
that for me that was what i felt like
when i was going through that strictly
stuff that i should get as a tattoo it's
like i
brought up
dad off his nuts and drugs
went to school didn't get a gcse but
ended up playing the o2 arena like i was
i felt like you know in a business that
is full of middle class yeah that make
you know middle class everywhere middle
class people
private school people people are a lot
of people that just their life is handed
to them but i've come in through this
other route and the world just went
bang yeah [ __ ] off oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know when you asked me i i initially
just gave it my story was sorry no no
it's much simpler my parents when i was
born my mom had been 18 for three days
my dad was 20 they were both students
really poor in soviet russia
fast forward a few years my dad becomes
a mini oligarch [ __ ] tons of money send
me to private school in england you know
son don't worry i was like maybe i
should get a job while i'm at school
just you know no don't worry about it
just get the grades you go to university
get the grades you're going to go to a
big financial company you know company
house company car company wife company
like everything taken care of and by the
time i was 18 my dad had lost all his
money for reasons we don't get it's too
long a story right and i was sleeping in
a park
[Laughter]
just loved getting back on the gear
sleeping
in a park in a park around the corner of
the venue where i did my first edinburgh
show around the corner i was in
university in edinburgh and i was
sleeping in that park for three weeks
just trying to get my [ __ ] together so
that arrogance
just gone in three weeks all that oh i'm
the top of the world i'm special i'm
different i'm this i'm that no no no no
you're right [ __ ] here in the past
that's quite the fall yeah yeah and it
happens quickly so i know that feeling
very well and
that's very young as well very young
and i'm glad it happened that young
because all that would have happened to
me is what happened to you i would have
just built my ego even more
i would have thought i'm i would have
got bigger and bigger in my own head and
in in the world you know because i was
smart i was talented i would have made
it through and i would have been bigger
and bigger and bigger
but i'm glad of that
and i think there will come a time when
you're glad of what you went through as
well remember that i also
yeah i i see what you're saying remember
i also i also caused a lot of pain
you know there you know
there were other people involved in mine
which you know you can't you can't ever
i mean i think everyone as far as i can
tell everyone involved has has gone on
and and
is having a
a good time and doing well for
themselves
but you split up she split up with her
husband didn't she yeah yes yeah they
got divorced and i think i've i mean i
don't i you know i try and stay away
from
any anything that is it's attached to
that whole yeah time in my in my uh in
my life but i think you know i think
everyone's doing everyone who's involved
in that is doing well and i wish them
well and i think that
but it just makes it a bit difficult so
it makes it easier that you can look
back and think oh i'm glad that happened
but you also have to always live with
you you still caused quite a lot of yeah
you know kind of
cause a wreckage in your in your path so
can i be glad it happened to me maybe
let's see where let's see where this
ends up but you know but also you know
with other people look you you've got to
take responsibility for your actions
yeah but they got to take responsibility
for their actions
well i'm not so i'm not getting involved
i'm not saying
yeah
but
that's going to be the time of the
episode sure
she needs to take responsibility
but it's true man
no no no no no no
we won't go there this is not my fault
no no no but but i i look uh these
things that happen in life they're very
important man they're very important
um they're very important
and you you you will you what you the
work you will do later in your life will
be better for it
hmm well yeah well
it will be yes
and it the kiss is a brilliant show it's
on youtube it's available for free
people can go and watch yes
and are you touring as well
we're touring i've got a podcast called
what's upset you now uh it's only 15
minutes long you can hear that and
there's an extended episode on patreon
but um yeah check out the
the you know if people are watching and
um
you know they want to know more about
what it was we're talking about even
though i think they've heard enough
there is a comedy version of it kiss on
youtube and also as well i think it's
important to say that i remember the
first time i saw you do comedy and i was
blown away i thought you were just
absolutely brilliant and when i said the
most naturally talented comedian on
stage
i meant
yeah yeah but
i i i always say that when everyone goes
to me what's your night i got the most
naturally
it's amazing and i've talented you crush
it at festivals cat laughs where you
you've been a few times uh while i was
there uh your great live comic and i
really recommend people get a ticket
come and see it oh thank you so much
been been lovely to uh to chat thanks
for having me on before we let you go
though we've got some questions from our
local supporters which we'll ask you
after the interview but the last
question we always ask is what's the one
thing we're not talking about that we
really should be
um
i think
uh
yes this is important
is one thing i think that that we need
to clear up as as and i don't know if
it's a national problem or a global
problem but um
the word next
when you say i'll meet you next thursday
so some people think next thursday is
the first day coming
and some people think next thursday
is the is the thursday
the following week the next week is that
is that thursday and i think we need to
get this cleared up because it's causing
a lot of confusion
and someone came to meet me
um
recently
and
and they they that i thought that they
they meant the next
i thought they meant the week after
do you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
what do you think next is nick i think
when someone goes next verse if i'm
meeting you so i'm going to meet you i'm
going to meet you next tuesday right
next so it depends on what day you're in
yeah
it depends what day we're in yeah this
is chaos this is why i'm saying this we
need to get this clear now hold on no i
don't think it's as complicated as
you're making out it is as complicated
i've not i'm didn't i was meant to be on
talk sport to do a radio and i didn't
make it
because i had said next thursday
and then they text me on the thursday of
that week and they said
where are you
and i said sorry i thought you meant
next i thought you meant the week after
because i i thought that most people
think the week after so i changed what i
thought it meant to
to fit them because i actually think
even that does though despite i did that
i actually think next is just the next
it's the next it's not of course imagine
you're at a queue
in a shop
and you're at the front of the queue and
the guy behind the counter said next and
the guy behind you walked round
you would think what the [ __ ] are you
doing you know he said next i'm next
you're not next
so can we just get this sold please what
do you think next time i've never seen
them this angry man yeah these are the
but these are the real issues this is
the these are the things that make
getting through life
tough
and this is what i'm trying to sort out
what is next well that's what we're
going to be talking about on the next
time the next episode no what do you
think next is it means next thursday
means not this thursday the one after
well it's thursday today so that's
confusing yeah so all right next okay so
next tue next tuesday
i think it's a tuesday afterwards you
what you think that next tuesday yeah
is look at you you've never
what do you think we've had jordan
peterson on the podcast
we've had douglas murray some of the
greatest thinkers in the history of the
modern world get jordan's get jordan
peterson to sort out where next is can
you do you have contact with jordan i do
can you find out what he thinks
they'll let you know yeah please
we will do you don't seem to be taking
it seriously
what do you think next tuesday is
next tuesday is the coming tuesday now
thank you because it's the next tuesday
yeah but if but
but if we if today was monday and you
said next tuesday that would be the
monday after this coming tuesday oh yeah
tuesday can't be tomorrow no you can't
say next tuesday it depends tomorrow
depends on the day you're in just like i
said
it does right yeah no but only if the
day you're ready sorry you didn't make
it to talk radio no i'm really really
sorry but it's not the fault of the
world
no it's the fault of the language we've
got one word that is meaning different
things
this has gone in a completely unexpected
direction sure
it needed to be spoken about there we go
that's why we asked the big questions
here guys thank you so much for watching
and listening uh make sure to follow
sean on all socials and uh check out his
special it's called kiss it's on youtube
we'll put a link to in the description
uh we're gonna ask a couple of your
questions for sean on our locals that
only our supporters will see in the
meantime thanks for watching where do i
look i don't know when to look when
you're doing that you're not going to be
talking we don't want to hear any more
from you about next i don't know when
you're looking
just look somewhere
no it's also available as a podcast [ __ ]
me we've had jordan peterson on the show
anyway
it was actually will smith punching
chris rock in the face and people there
are people that go but would you let
would you let someone say that about
your partner
they wouldn't have to
i would have done it
i would have come in and been like look
it's the old bald and chain one more
it was mad
[Music]
you